it's time for July's PS plus extra and
premium updates bringing even more games
to the catalog my job is to Showcase all
the games coming to the service on July
18th and your job is to decide what to
play please do me a favor and recommend
a game in the comments to help those who
are paralyzed by choice I'm Adam hello
there let's do this on the extra tier of
PlayStation Plus this month is the game
of the year from 2021. it takes two a
co-op only split screen game in which a
quarreling set of parents are turned
into toys and must work together to get
back to the real world and back to their
daughter mechanically it takes two is a
platformer but it switches genres
hundreds of times as each level requires
a slightly different skill set it's
absolutely littered with mini games to
play and on top of that it's a really
good platinum trophy well worth your
time put simply it takes two is amazing
snow Runner is next up on PS4 and PS5 a
simulation of TV programs like Ice Road
Truckers as we take to the driver's seat
and Conquer environments that border on
Impossible from mud and torrents of
water to frozen lakes and constant
snowstorms the contracts we face in this
game are insane real world vehicles have
been recreated such as Ford and
Chevrolet to name a few and where they
are riding solo or in a four-player
co-op session snow Runner isn't for the
faint-hearted and some sections take a
great deal of skill but you can do it I
have faith in you the more hardcore
games this month include World War Z or
World War Zed if you prefer yet another
Co-op game as four players face swarms
of zombies in a third person firefight
the story campaign follows the same
format as the movies as survival is
Paramount and a cool little touch is
each member of the group has their own
story of how they got there it's a
simple premise prepare for attack and
defend your objective until you've taken
them all out and there's also a PVP mode
if fighting AI zombies isn't enough for
you next an RPG and yet again it's a
Cooperative experience if you want it to
be the ascent plays like a twin stick
shooter but it evolves past that quickly
with a cover system and a unique weapon
range mechanic then the cyberpunk
inspired World takes over as augments
are unlocked that can change our
character fundamentally whether that's
just basic hacking skills or the ability
to destroy walls that were once
impossible to even scratch the reviews
are very mixed with highs of 9 out of 10
and lowers of sixes so the only way you
can really know for sure is to play it
yourself or to check in the comments I
guess as with many games like this
playing in a group of four really
improves The Experience now I just need
to find three friends another RPG which
goes in a completely different direction
is dismantle a survival role-playing
game where almost anything you see can
be broken and used to craft new items
not only that but you'll be cutting
through monster hordes and harvesting
their husks once safe dismantle becomes
like a life Sim with farming fishing and
hunting all in the knowledge that those
husks will never give up Escape is your
only option a third RPG this month with
a drastically different idea is Circus
electric I've probably said that wrong a
story-based RPG set in London where we
select different circus performers who
each have unique skills to fight and
defend it then becomes a turn-based
attack and defense scenario like old
jrpgs and your focus is to plan
strategies before executing them in
battle but without a doubt the story is
sent to stage in Circus electric it's
like the greatest showman next onto
SpongeBob SquarePants Battle for Bikini
Bottom rehydrated the game from 2003 has
been dragged up to date as SpongeBob
Patrick and Sandy are all playable
characters who can be switched to and
from freely at a bus stop no less each
character has a different skill set
making impossible paths accessible to
the right characters for our Nostalgia
here to this platform of rehydrated is
great and reviewers say this is a 69 out
of 100. speaking of older games the 2015
legendary undertale is here a single
player don't engine style role-playing
game which completely turns your
expectations against you like talking
your way out of boss fights and making
friends but when that fails you'll
experience a different type of fight
mechanic which is like a 2d bullet hell
using your cursor to avoid numerous
enemies on screen it's like return all
but in 2D undertale was made by one
person Toby Fox and has an average
review score of 92 out of 100 because
undertale is legendary if you need
something more intense then take a look
at Sniper Elite 5. the long-running
third person shooter is all about
Stealth and finding the right location
to use your scope to pop a few shots off
before relocating to fool your enemies
into looking in the wrong places Sniper
Elite 5 is set in World War II with
historically accurate weapons so it's
not all about your sniper rifle but this
game is totally known for one reason
bullet time X-ray and it's still as
amazing as it's always been the single
player campaign is supported by online
multiplayer to have a snipe off with
your real life Friends next the game
game of the month My Little Pony a
maritime bay Adventure follow Bronies
out there play as Sunny The Adventurous
earth pony who has magical powers by the
way we are tasked with bringing the
magic back to the town and go on the
occasional epic fashion show too I know
you're tempted by this I completely
understand we have a few melee focused
games Landing this month Dynasty
Warriors 9. hang on would you say
Dynasty Warriors well however you want
to say it that continues the
long-running series and it's all about
hack and slash addictiveness endless
waves of foes flood the screen and you
single-handedly take them all down cause
you're about us Dynasty Warriors tends
to focus on Chinese history whereas
samurai warrior 5 continues the hack and
slash theme but this time in a more
Japanese Vibe samurai warrior has
evolved and includes Citadel mode which
is like a tower defense style approach
with unlockable upgrades another
fighting game with far less going on on
screen is melty blood type Lumina it's
the usual one-on-one fighter with light
heavy and medium attacks used to beat
your foes to a pulp for for a 2d fighter
it's highly regarded but often
overlooked and finally a couple of races
to finish first Monster Jam steel Titans
take the iconic monster trucks and has
them race on 25 different tracks from
stadiums to Sandy Dunes with stunt and
destruction challenges to break up the
flow and last but not least a game all
about family Fast and Furious spy Racers
rise of shifter an excruciatingly
mediocre racer with some Innovative
shortcuts and secrets there's 17 tracks
across five locations and to keep things
PG you'll be shooting foes with a paint
gun because family takes care of each
other sadly the hand that giveth also
taketh away and this month we are losing
10 games including some real big ones
like stray the story of the cat trying
to make its way back home will be
leaving PS plus extra on Tuesday July
18th alongside the entire Bioshock
Trilogy remastered also going is the
Borderlands Handsome Jack collection
which contains Borderlands 2 and the
Pre-Sequel and the ill fade Marvel's
Avengers that I seem to be the only
person in the entire world who enjoyed
that's going to Saints Row got out of
hell ride in five Rogue stormers and the
fluster cluck I'm glad I said that right
I'm going bye-byes too so you have less
than one week to play any of those games
before they are locked away for a while
at least if you haven't played today
definitely try that one looks a great
little game and lastly over to PS Plus
premium our options this month include
Twisted Metal One and Two originally on
the PS1 these things were cutting edge
battle Racers with some awesome
characters and in general they were just
cool it's such a shame what happened to
that series and finally there's a PSP
game it's Gravity Rush portable a space
shooter I'm still not sure if premium is
worth the extra money you know anyway
that's our month what you're playing
I'll be jumping back into SpongeBob
SquarePants and dismantle looks like my
kind of game what you're playing I
imagine my voice is going I love you
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you